pilot c'est ça c'est une petite pile qui
se recharge par le mouvement et vous l'a
secoué comme ça et vous pouvez la sallaz
permet de la recharge est alors
l'intérêt c'est que ça permet de
recharger des petits objets comme une
télécommande des manettes de jeu des
thermomètres sadc génère un tout petit
peu d'énergie mais en revanche sale je
rêve toujours donc vous êtes toujours
prêt et c'est écolo puisque c'est il n'y
a pas de batterie a pas de métaux lourds
comme on va trouver habituellement dans
ce genre de système et en même temps sa
durée de vie de 10 ans donc et sa
garantie
du coup vous êtes plus jamais à court de
pied que comment j'ai fait comment j'ai
eu cette idée en quoi c'est important et
c'est ça que je vais essayer de vous
expliquer et j'ai vous surtout votre
vous montrer à travers ces quelques
minutes
les commandeurs le parcours de
l'invention de l'idée jusqu'à
l'invention alors l'idée j'ai eu quand
j'étais en lune de miel en colombie en
fait je me promenais à sac à dos dans un
parc naturel et j'avais j'étais email a
dit qu'il ya eu leur achètent toujours
j'ai besoin de vérifier mes mails de
savoir ce qui se passe et je n'avais pas
bah j'avais à pour téléphone il y avait
du réseau cellulaire
mais comme c'était un parc naturel
n'avaient pas de câble électrique vous
pouvez pas branché et je trouvais ça
dommage parce que je marchais et s'y
faisait chaud il y avait de la lumière
donc tout était prêt et avec beaucoup
d'énergie mais on pouvait pas le
réinjecter dans mon téléphone et je ne
savais pas ce qui se passait à paris bon
ça a l'air de rien mais c'était un gros
problème pour moi à l'époque psychologie
que réellement bien sûr et il est donc
en réfléchissant autour de ça je me suis
rendu compte que au delà de mon besoin
particulier de vérifier mes mails on a
des objets électroniques de
l'électronique partout autour de nous on
a besoin partout autour de nous on a
besoin de cette source d'énergie est
et finalement il ya plein de gens qui
ont ce problème ne pas recharger leurs
objets alors qu'ils en ont besoin et
donc en rentrant en france
j'ai travaillé j'ai réfléchi à ça donc
j'ai regardé ce qui existait on avait
déjà de l'énergie avait déjà des
chargeurs solaires qui existait des
chargeurs à manivelle
j'en étais j'en ai acheté plein je les
ai tous testé beaucoup et ça
fonctionnait pas ça fonctionne très très
mal j'ai regardé la science la science
c'est un domaine scientifique qui
s'appelle l'énergie harvesting pour
récolte d'énergie en anglais ça arrive
c'est toute cette sphère tu cherches
l'arrière parce qu'on se fait ce qu'on
fait c'est récupérer de l'énergie de
l'environnement ça commence à
fonctionner rond là des petites choses
mais c'est le début et je me suis j'ai
fabriqué des preuves de concept des
tests j'ai regardé ce qu'on pouvait
faire et en travaillant comme ça pendant
quelques mois je me suis dit tiens qui
si on pouvait remplacer toutes les piles
si on pouvait remplacer toutes les
batteries qu'est-ce que ça qu'est ce que
ça donnerait et est ce que c'est
possible donc
donc j'en ai parlé autour de moi j'ai ri
de montrer un peu mais des mots j'ai
regardé et je me suis rendu compte que
j'avais touché un vrai problème qui est
piqué par chance un pur ans puisque je
vais vraiment je vais rarement hors de
paris et du coup j'avais vraiment j'ai
vraiment eu de la chance là dessus donc
je me suis j'ai creusé quoi et donc je
me suis rendu compte que 1 once un
problème on met de l'électronique
partout dans nos objets actuellement
plus plus le temps passe et plus on met
de l'électronique partout donc on a même
dans vos ampoules électriques et il y en
aura de plus en plus parce que ça coûte
de moins en moins cher de la même
manière
en corollaire la batterie c'est le
maillon faible de tous ces dispositifs
faut savoir qu'une batterie même coup
une plaine fertile rechargeable ou même
une pile rechargeable pardon vous allez
la charge et 3000 fois au maximum après
elle est bonne à mettre à la poubelle
c'est pour ça on occurrence que souvent
vous devez changer de téléphone et que
au bout d'un peu de temps la batterie
dure de moins en moins longtemps
c'est des systèmes qui ont cru qu'ils
sont des systèmes chimique et qui ont
une capacité de charge décharge maximale
il existe d'autres pilki ceux qui sont
très chers mais qui fonctionne bien
enfin ce qui fonctionne plus longtemps
et donc c'est vraiment le maillon faible
de tous ces systèmes c'est pour ça qu'on
peut pas légal et c'est pour ça qu'on
n'arrive pas à les garder et alors
ensuite il ya un autre facteur qui joue
qui s'appelle
le des nordiques henning c'est du 2e 2e
ard pour ceux que ça intéresse ces
insectes et d'un scientifique qui a
beaucoup travaillé sur la physique des
semi conducteurs et il s'est rendu
compte que là que les que les
transistors la puissance consommée
d'étranges histoires étaient divisés par
deux tous les 18 mois
ce que ça veut dire concrètement c'est
que tous les 18 mois il faut deux fois
moins d'énergie pour accomplir la même
tâche dans un semi conducteurs et ça
c'est très important parce que ça veut
dire que finalement pour un objet comme
télécommande tout le travail de
traitement de l'information
c'est à dire savoir le bouton envoyer
transformer l'impulsion en ondes
électromagnétiques ce genre de choses ça
ça consomme de moins en moins d'énergie
et donc dix ans après on est on en a
presque baissé on a divisé par plus de
deux le cse la consommation totale
et donc ces technologies d'énergie
investigue deviennent de plus en plus
accessible dans le sens où on peut faire
de plus en plus de choses avec ça donc
on était vraiment tout avait l'air monde
était vraiment dans un sas avait l'air
vraiment d'être un domaine prometteur
et pourtant il y avait rien bah on n'en
trouvait pas sur le marché à part des
petits gadgets
du coup j'ai réfléchi autour de ça j'ai
continué à travailler
j'ai mis un petit peu de moyens dans le
temps le système pendant cette idée
gerbaud j'ai rencontré quelqu'un qui se
fit terminer juste son doctorat
s'appelait robin avec qui on a toujours
tout fait on a travaillé ensemble
pendant un an ou deux abordera non
pardon et résultats bas c'est toujours
ça on a sorti ça et ça fonctionne donc
c'est ça qui est bien et donc donc du
coup j'imagine que vous voulez pas
l'imposer du coup j'imagine aussi que
vous vous demandez comment ça marche
parce que ça a l'air un peu magique
en fait c'est mazet sur un principe qui
est vraiment très ancien qui est celui
de l'induction électromagnétique
donc vous avez un petit et manque et qui
circulent là dedans et donc quand je
déplace la pile quand je la secoue le
léman va se déplacer
on va là on a une bobine autour de
l'aimant qui va qui est donc c'est comme
ça qu'on génère de l'électricité
on transforme cette énergie de
déplacement en électricité donc c'est
assez simple c'est pas
c'est pas révolutionnaire ce principe là
en revanche l'application est nouvelle
et après on a dû mettre aussi quand même
pas mal d'électronique il ya des petites
choses qui ont plus qu on a rajouté sur
lequel on en train de poser des brevets
mais ces choses là on va quand enfin on
va quand même beaucoup plus loin c'est
quand même un nom de travail pour deux
personnes en même temps on arrive à
gérer ça alors pour vous donner des
idées un peu de quantitative un
mouvement comme ça ça génère donc 10
milliwatts en puissance instantanée donc
ça veut dire que en faisant 103 ans et
pour 3 x 2 sur 2 si les deux kills
pardon dans une télécommande et jeu-là
ce coût trois fois je peux changer de
chaîne une fois sur ma télécommande
alors en fonction des télécommandes ça
va être une fois ou deux des fois ça va
être un peu plus mais c'est ce genre de
cet ordre d'idée de cuisson donc c'est
passé par exemple pour alimenter une
langue une lampe de poche
en revanche tassé pour alimenter l'aide
pour un vélo qui devant sa bouche tout
ça permet pas mal de choses en fait ce
genre de mouvements aussi ça permet
aussi d'art peut aussi imaginer faire
une souris sans fil sans pile on a des
prototypes comme ça qu'ils fonctionnent
où il n'ya pas de la souris en fait en
la déplaçant sur un principe un petit
peu similaire le mouvement va générer de
l'énergie qui va permettre de mettre à
jour la position de la souris et donc on
a plus besoin de payer donc c'est ce
genre de choses en fait et c'est un cc
comment dire c'était vraiment
intéressant de le faire sur le coup on
sait pas vraiment rendu compte que
c'était que c'était comme mozart à que
c'était nous
ça paraissait juste logique on a suivi
le chemin est on arrivé là
et après quand on en a parlé un peu
autour de nous tout le monde faisait
jiahua c'est cool c'est bien mais sur le
court ce n'était pas rendu compte en
banque et du cou et du coup c'est ça en
fait qu'on vous condamnera confessé pour
la réussit donc ça c'est déjà pas mal et
en plus on voit déjà la suite c'est pour
ça qu'on s'en était pas rendu compte
parce que la suite c'est quoi la suite
c'est une fois qu'on a ça va faut
commencer on a ouvert les précommandes
sur nos sites
il faut commencer à les fabriquer du
coup faut les livrets pour trouver
retrouver des industriels avec qui on va
travailler fort prévoit améliorer aussi
la suite faut améliorer ce système là
ensuite
sage vers 10 milliwatts cet effet avec
avec des technologies très low cost en
sait un peu d'entraînement 3d un peu de
soudure et puis dès maintenant et si on
fait ça et qu'on arrive à avoir ce genre
de résultats tout de suite ça veut dire
que dans 2 3 ans en mettant plus de
moyens en travaillant sur chaque couche
du système on peut multiplier par 2 par
3 les résultats et ensuite on peut aussi
imaginer faire faire d'autres générateur
c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire par
exemple pour que dans cinq ans la
plupart de vos objets de petits objets
de ce type là mais plus de batterie ça
vous commencez déjà à les avoir mais si
vous vous demandez peut-être pas aux
grands comptes
d'ailleurs philippe sa sortie a pas
longtemps une lente que vous trouvez sur
l'apple store faille dans pool qui sert
tendance mise et philippe qui qui qui
permet de changer de couleur je sais pas
si vous êtes familier avec ce truc là je
connais plus le nom et la télécommande
en fait là pas de pile
donc ça marche sur un autre système que
nous mais ils ont déjà sorti ça aussi
donc ça veut dire qu'on est vraiment
dans un domaine qui vous et c'est à kéké
qui est intéressant c'est que deux
bogeys et et nous par rapport à ça
justement phillips a gardé cette
technologie pour eux pour eux mêmes ils
sont pas posé plus de questions 520
ouest c'est cool on va le garder pour
nous nous on s'est dit mais là on rentre
un peu dans l' approche business on
s'est dit qu'est ce qu'on va faire avec
ça on peut fabriquer nos objets on
pourrait fabriquer le sourire on a fait
des prototypes on pourrait fabriquer nos
télécommandes sont pile on va vendre
oddo cie ses fils et ont saisi en fait
ce qui est intéressant c'est de d'ouvrir
sa à tout le monde à tout ce qu'on veut
aller qui puisse le mettre dans tous
leurs objets on s'aime n'est pas capable
de prévoir les applications donc ce
qu'on a fait c'est qu'on en train de se
structurer pour vendre directement des
générateurs pour expliquer à tout le
monde comment fabriquer ce genre d'objet
mais ce qu'il faut c'est ce qui est
compliqué aussi c'est qu'il faut revoir
l'objet derrière souvent pour que ça
marche bien et donc d'être très très
ouvert aux licences en fait de vendre
des licences plutôt que fabriquer de la
technologie qui indirectement de maximis
pas notre profit mais ça permet de
diffuser le plus largement possible le
plus vite possible et ça c'est ce que ce
que je pensais important parce que faut
pas oublier que les pires c'est c'était
cette source les piles et les batteries
c'est source majeure de pollution dans
le monde
il faut savoir que juste en france des
piles comme ça donc double à ils sont
600 millions juste en france sachant que
la france c'est pas le plus gros
consommateur de payer puisque on a
beaucoup de tous les objets d'antan des
batteries rechargeables
quand vous achetez des télécommandes
souvent elles sont livrées avec des
piles rechargeables les téléphones en
queue de file donc c'est vraiment un
objet en fin saison c'est pas le plus
gros marché et ce à un moment on en vend
600 millions donc deux piles dans juste
en france par an c'est énorme quand vous
y pensez et donc si vous rajoutez les
batteries les piles etc
on arrive tout de suite à des dizaines
de millers d'unités vendues et c'est des
choses que vous devez changer et pour
vous une pile et puis le traditionnel
par exemple c'est quelque chose de très
polluants et vous allez par exemple si
on m'avait raconté cette histoire en
afrique il ya des gens qui les met qui
les jettent dans des champs et ça va
polluer le champ sur plusieurs
générations de la même et donc ils font
beaucoup de campagnes au brésil vous
avez ça aussi font beaucoup de campagnes
pour expliquer qu'il faut pas jeter les
piles pour créer ces filières de
recyclage qu'on ados en france et alors
pour allait même plus loin il y en a eu
avec elle avait raconté comme ça une
histoire en afrique de quelqu'un qui
utilisaient la poudre contenue dans les
piles comme un ordre est parce que comme
c'était d'énergie si je la mettais dans
la côte est dont il utilisé comme
engrais dans ma plante jamais demandé de
l'énergie à ma plante donc c'était ça
son raisonnement qui était plutôt mal en
fait mais joe et dodo donc c'est
vraiment enfin ce que j'ai donné à fait
que c'est vraiment dangereux
beaucoup plus important que ce qu'on
peut penser et au delà d'un produit qui
allait peut-être un peu gadget qui parce
que finalement pour l'instant ça ne sert
qu'à des télécommandes
derrière on a vraiment l'ambition que et
fait aussi le sens de cette technologie
de remplacer toutes les piles ou dans la
majorité des cas de tous les objets à
faible puissance donc téléphone
république voilà merci beaucoup